if you want to see all the references to
the original Halloween films then stick
around to the end of this video
halloween is coming again this year
I mean Halloween a holiday comes around
every year but Halloween the movie has
only come 11 out of the last 40 years so
that's a pretty rare occurrence that's
only twenty-seven point five percent of
the years so yeah I'm gonna shut up now
and do the things you missed so if you
pause on the shot of the
trick-or-treaters and yes I realize I
can't shut up and tell you the things
you missed because I have to talk to do
this but you know what I meant but if
you pausing the trick-or-treaters
there's actually a girl wearing an
adjacent sand jersey and for those of
you who were not here for the 90s Oh Jay
was a pro running back who most people
would agree killed his wife and her
friend and got away with it there was
this huge trial it was a really big deal
and OJ was ultimately found not guilty
despite a lot of evidence going against
him you know who else stabbed his
victims to death and got away with it
that's right Michael Myers did that
stuff the only difference is that
Michael didn't write a book about how he
would have done it
forty-seven seconds into the new trailer
there's a scene of a woman wearing a
pink bathrobe with curlers in her hair
making a ham sandwich in her kitchen
Michael goes in and comes out with a
knife presumably after some altercation
because the chair is flipped over in the
second shot this is a remake of a scene
from the original Halloween 2 that came
out in 1981
it's also how Michael gets his knife in
that movie as you may know the new
Halloween film for 2018 is the second
movie in this timeline with Halloween -
and everything that comes after it
having never taken place here just the
original Halloween and Halloween 2018
Halloween 2018 is essentially the new
Halloween - so it's interesting to see
that the events from the 1981 Halloween
- are still taking place almost as if
they were destined to happen no matter
what other events take place to change
the world line this next one I'm not
counting as one of the things you missed
because there's really no significance
to it but I just thought it would be fun
to point out but this jack-o'-lantern
looks like the logo of the smiler pretty
well-known infinity coaster at Alton
Towers as we move up to the house the
shots here of Michael looking through
the window at what appears to be a woman
on the phone could be a reference to
this scene also from the first act of
the 1981 Halloween - there's also a
graveyard scene in the trailer where a
figure is spotted hiding behind a tree
wearing all white while we don't know
for sure that this is Michael it
wouldn't make sense the white clothes
likely indicate that he had just escaped
from the sanitarium and headed straight
for his sister's grave just as he does
in the original Halloween where he
steals his sister's tombstone and later
uses it as a prop to display one of his
killings
this time however Laurie is going to be
prepared for Michaels onslaught she's
stocked up with weapons one of which is
marked with a lightning bolt and has the
letters K s there is a character named
Cara strode who's Laurie's cousin in the
1995 film Halloween the curse of michael
myers.slc Laurie even tells her daughter
that she needs to step up her security
so I think Laurie bought this gun for
Karen to protect herself but Karen is
probably hesitant to use it until later
in the movie when she actually
encounters Michael and sees why he's so
dangerous in a video I did on the
previous Halloween trailer which you can
watch right here I pointed out that some
of the trick-or-treaters were wearing
the silver shamrock mask from Halloween
3 if you're not familiar with that movie
silver shamrock is
evil company that aggressively
advertises in sells children's Halloween
masks that when activated caused this to
happen in the new trailer we get a
better look at the masks and see that
all three of them are presents please
keep in mind that this does not take
place in the same universe as Halloween
3 and the appearance of these masks is
probably just an easter egg at the end
of the trailer when Laurie's
hysterically waving the gun around her
light briefly shines onto a closet where
one of Michael's victims has been stored
on the top shelf
at least he's tidy and organized I don't
think Oh Jay Simpson can make that same
claim did you catch anything that I
missed in the trailer what do you make
of the number 330 being written on the
shack what is this text on the
jack-o'-lantern say would you watch a
horror franchise about OJ Simpson as the
slasher where he's miraculously found
not guilty at the end of every movie let
me know in the comments if you learned
something new about this trailer today
leave this video a like and if you love
horror if you're interested in more
content related to the new Halloween
film or if you're down and listened to
some scary story narrations then
remember subscribe to seize these worlds
for new Horrors every week ring that
death bell for notifications and I'll
see you in the next one assuming we both
survive